[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce tout
premier numéro du satuc loisirs de la
saison chaque jeudi nous vous
proposeront des idées de sorties pour
votre week end dans les yvelines tout de
suite le sommaire les week-end les
journées du patrimoine reviennent pour
une 37e édition ce week end deux jours
où de nombreux événements vous seront
proposées notamment sur saint quentin en
yvelines
nous reviendrons sur les coups de coeur
de la rédaction dernière étape du tour
de france ce dimanche 20 septembre
elle partira de mantes la jolie notre
journaliste justin brasier nous donnera
les détails des animations organisées
et puis enfin l'agent dé l'agenda
complet de vos sorties du week end
au programme un événement élan pour toi
et il fait aux mureaux si il y à un
rendez vous à ne pas manquer en
septembre ce sont les journées du
patrimoine
cette année elles se tiendront ce samedi
19 et dimanche 20 septembre
la programmation de saint quentin en
yvelines est maintenu malgré la crise
sanitaire
astrid bergère a donc sélectionné les
coups de coeur de rédaction dans les
yvelines de nombreuses animations auront
lieu pour les trente septième journée du
patrimoine
parmi elles une visite originale de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la compagnie à une paix eu l'
agence nationale de psychanalyse urbaine
qui s'en chargera l'idée est de
découvrir sous un autre angle les lieux
où l'on passe tous les jours on se rend
pas vraiment compte en fait de tout ce
que l'on dit en regardant sur
l'environnement toujours sous le mans
sous la main sous le même angle pardon
est là l'idée c'est vraiment de décaler
drogue le regard et de se dire en fait
comment se fait-il que je n'ai pas vu
cette chose qui sous mes yeux
le point de rendez vous est donné au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
14h30 le samedi 19 et le dimanche 20
les organisateurs rappellent que la
réservation est obligatoire et que les
participants marcheront deux à trois
kilomètres
autre événement coup de coeur ce
week-end des spectacles de danse
verticale
ça veut dire que c'est une danse qui est
ouverte est possible pour tous les âges
absolument et pas seulement pour les des
grands habitués la danse contemporaine
mais
vraiment pour tous les publics l'idée dé
cette pratique c'est d'utiliser les murs
des édifices ou des bâtiments pour
danser la ville pour nous est un espace
qui est complètement ouvert à notre
notre danse et en plus on quelque part
on invente un nouvel usage à la ville
puisque on vient on arrive avec nos
cordes no baudriller tout ce matériel
d'escaladé mais avec un avec une
recherche chorégraphique des spectacles
de danse à découvrir à montigny le
bretonneux et à elancourt et faisons un
tour d'horizon des autres événements du
département a commencé par une visite
insolite à la bibliothèque centrale de
versailles
samedi 19 septembre de 11 heures à 17
heures la bibliothèque patrimoniale
ouvre ses portes
vous pourrez découvrir les secrets et
les anecdotes kelly cash et si vous
préférez plus de nature les journées
agriculture et patrimoine à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet vous offre
toutes sortes d'animations durant deux
jours de 11 heures à 18 heures pour les
plus jeunes les enfants pourront se
mettre dans la peau d'un berger un
apiculteur ou encore un vacher et enfin
le domaine de dampierre en yvelines
montrera en avant première samedi et
dimanche de 10h à 17h30
quelques voitures hippomobiles datant du
19e siècle
le public pourra même monté dedans
d'après le directeur général du domaine
notre envie c'est bien de montrer direct
vraiment et que les gens prennent leur
est normal pour mener pour voir quel
effet ça fait que d'être sur un siège
d'une voiture hippomobile et d'avoir de
francs soit quatre chevaux qui vous
mènent nos valeurs on est vraiment l'art
vivant par excellence des rats non
seulement l'art vivant puisque on est
sur un patrimoine qui va déambuler
autour du château et sur les pelouses du
château mais aussi l'art vivant sont au
sens où le public va se l'approprier
[Musique]
et on quitte le monde de la culture pour
celui de l'environnement ramasser les
déchets pour un monde plus propre
le board skin of day aura lieu ce samedi
19 septembre dans de nombreuses villes
du monde à voisins le bretonneux il se
tiendra de 10h à 12h plus d'informations
dans l'interview express avec béatrice
pire à la coordinatrice de l'événement
[Musique]
le world kindness est un événement
mondial qui a lieu cette année le 19
septembre 2020 et le principe est de
ramasser les déchets d'engager les
citoyens les associations pour fédérer
toutes les énergies et ramasser les
déchets qui polluent notre environnement
[Musique]
on va faire des petits groupes qui vont
ramasser les papiers les cartons les
bouteilles en verre les bouteilles en
plastique les canettes et aussi les
mégots nous allons collecter ces déchets
qui seront ensuite repris par les
services municipaux pour nettoyer notre
ville à la rendre encore plus agréable
le but de cette opération est de
nettoyer notre cadre de vie de nettoyer
la planète de créer aussi une force
collective et citoyenne pour lancer ces
mouvements comme vous l'avez dit qu'il
devienne habituel c'est-à-dire que
chacun prenne l'habitude de ramasser
quand il rencontre des déchets et puis
aussi à la maison réduire ses déchets
triés et recyclés données lancer toute
cette dynamique autour du zéro déchet
tout le monde peut venir tous ceux qui
ont envie de participer et qui se
sentent motivés
est intéressé pour aider à nettoyer
notre cadre de vie
rendez vous nous rendez vous donc au
centre de loisirs de
voisins-le-bretonneux top départ à 10
heures et je vous le disais en titre
dimanche 20 septembre marque le coup
d'envoi de la dernière étape du tour de
france les coureurs vont partir de
mantes la jolie
avant de rejoindre les champs elysées la
caravane s'élancera à 14 heures depuis
le stade nautique international pour en
parler avec nous de l'événement donc
j'estime brasier bonsoir avant soit on
est à trois jours de l'arrivée du tour
de france
exactement c'est ça donc aujourd'hui
c'était la 18e étape les coureurs sont
partis de méribel et c'est le slovène
primoz through glitch en maillot jaune
donc mais c'est michal katkov ce qui est
arrivé en tête sur roche sur foron alors
le départ vous le disiez célia de la
dernière étape aura lieu en effet à
mantes la jolie à 15h45 pour l'occasion
la ville a organisé un week-end dédié au
vélo il y aura de nombreuses animations
même si celle de l'association sportive
mantaise sont annulés mais il y aura par
exemple un rippeur café ou encore des
prêts de vélos en ville en bord de seine
au stade nautique
en fait ils souhaitent faire de un
maximum de personnes utilisent le vélo
le ton de ce week end pour essayer de
changer un peu les comportements à leur
échelle on aura des animations pour
apprendre aux gens à réparer leur vélo
on aux actions avec des courses
virtuelles ou des gens s'affronteront
dans des petites courses on aura une
exposition de vieux vélos fin on a
vraiment faire entrer ce thème à
l'intérieur de la ville les yvelines
sont un département de vélo donc là
vraiment profite de ce qui arrive et
d'accueil de cet événement mondial pour
faire en sorte que un maximum de menté
plutôt prendre leur voiture
pendant le week-end est-ce que des
dispositifs importante était mise en
place due à la crise sanitaire
oui bah cette année sera un peu
différente des éditions précédentes
en fait donc bien sûr le port du masque
sera obligatoire les distances sociales
à respecter mais en plus de ça les
autographes les selles fille ne seront
pas autorisés il faut aussi savoir que
la hes-so donc les organisateurs de la
course ont annulé leurs événements
dimanche et puis cette année on pourra -
voir les coureurs que d'habitude j'ai
une bulle sanitaire autour des coureurs
qui fait qu'on ne peut pas rassembler un
trop grand nombre de gens et pour ceux
qui ont déjà fait un village du tour de
france hier beaucoup beaucoup de monde
d'habitude donc ce serait pas
raisonnable dans les conditions
sanitaires qui sont les nôtres on a eu
peur jusqu'au dernier moment que ce tour
de france n'ait pas lieu
donc on roule l'accueil avec plaisir
dans des conditions qui certes
particulière mais qui devrait nous
permettre quand même de pouvoir faire la
fête tout en étant responsable et
raisonnable
j'imagine donc que c'est une fierté pour
les mantes et d'accueillir la dernière
étape du tour de france
et oui ils ont hâte de faire découvrir à
mantes-la-jolie de changer en fait leur
image grâce à la visibilité que va leur
offrir l'événement les habitants donc se
sont préparés ils ont affiché la couleur
jaune un peu partout en ville mais aussi
des drapeaux et il espère avoir du monde
j'attends du monde et surtout j'attende
enthousiasme parce que l' avantage du
tour de france et que ça va nous un
événement sportif qui passe devant les
fenêtres des gens donc que je pense
qu'on va voir beaucoup de monde au sol
mais aussi aux fenêtres pour saluer le
passage des coureurs
la de mammeri je vois des gens qui ont
accroché à leurs fenêtres des maillots
jaunes des maillots à pois des maillots
verts on a décoré la ville
pour ce qui est du parcours dans la
ville elle les coureurs je le rappelle
partiront à 15h45
ils vont longer les bords de seine et
remonteront ensuite par le boulevard des
signes juste avant le quai de la tour et
puis ils passeront au pied de la
collégiale
merci justin pour toute cette
information et puis on va on se retrouve
jeudi prochain avec plaisir cette
semaine c'est la rentrée pour les
associations sportives à voisins le
bretonneux les enfants du judo club ont
retrouvé le tatami après des mois
d'arrêt dû à la crise sanitaire cette
année il reste encore des places pour
s'inscrire
le montage de rémi lefebvre mettez vous
debout mais de vous
commence à lui se déplacer ou encore
respecter son adversaire
cette année la section de judo ce1 ce2
va apprendre de nouvelles règles et de
nouvelles prises l'an dernier la saison
a été impactée par le coronavirus les
enfants sont donc heureux de retrouver
leurs camarades et leurs kimonos
on a fait quelques prises on a fait des
déplacements et j'ai trouvé que c'était
bien et j'aime à peu près tout ya des
prises
on a pris une année dernière phase que
j'avais tellement par un prix en effet
les cours ont repris le 7 septembre avec
un groupe de huit enfants plus ou moins
débutants ont fait voir que je doute l
entraide entre les ce qu'ils ont fait un
peu du doubs depuis un an ou deux avec
des débutants qui commence cette année
donc il dit ils ont appris les bases à
savoir un peu la chute et les
déplacements qui permettent eux ne
bougent et à 2 sur le tapis savoir tenir
le lac mono avec 40 % d'inscriptions en
moins des places sont encore disponibles
pour s'initie au judo cette baisse
d'adhérents est certainement dû à la
crainte de l'aco vide
les parents n'ont pas encore tous
confiance avec dont je pense que dans
quinze jours trois semaines on saura où
on en est au point de vue des effectifs
d'une part de la réinscription des
enfants et pourtant toutes les mesures
sanitaires sont respectées pour passer
un moment de détente en passant par les
vestiaires en chine tarde pas on vient
directement sur le tapis
le judo club de voisins-le-bretonneux
accueille des enfants mais aussi des
adultes
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire pour
espérer un jour atteindre la ceinture
noire et au programme de ce week-end de
fleurs en scène revient pour une 17e
édition le parc de l'oso ré ouvrira ses
portes pour la fête des plantes et du
jardin aux mureaux cette année la plante
mise à l'honneur sera le fuchsia
l'association les amis du passé
d'elancourt organise dimanche 20
septembre la fête des vendanges à la
ferme du mousseau
pour la vingt septième édition les
enfants pourront gratuitement collecter
les grappes les foulées au pied et
participer au pressoir
cela fait vingt ans maintenant que le
site internet la gazette des sorciers
inspiré du célèbre journal d'harry
potter
existent pour fêter ça de nombreux fans
se sont réunis samedi à l'orangerie du
château de thoiry nicolas landry et
bixente mais rien son parti à leur
rencontre en dollars us
les apprentis sorciers sont à la fête
plus de 500 fans de la saga présents
pour célébrer la 20e année du plus
ancien site internet francophones autour
d'harry potter
on raconte l'actualité du monde d'harry
potter des animaux fantastiques les
nouvelles sorties de livres de films les
produits dérivés les parcs mais aussi on
va un peu plus loin on fait des articles
qui analysent l'univers qui le décrivent
qui décortique veut dire qu'on n'est pas
revenir à rester jusque
jusqu'aujourd'hui qu'on a continué à
vivre quel fandom harry potter est
toujours là et que la gazette est
toujours là c'est juste magique une
journée en immersion à l'orangerie du
château de thoiry au coeur de l'univers
de la magie
c'est un moyen de s'échapper un peu de
de s'imaginer dans le monde dans un
autre monde où la sorcellerie et est
intégré à la vie et et voilà ça nous
permet de rêver aussi
on peut partager des anecdotes des
choses qu'on a lu récemment parce que
l'univers est vaste éventuellement je
vais s'amuser à chercher les
incohérences et puis essayer de se
chercher qui connaît mieux tel ou tel
sujet entre deux conférences étaient
organisés également des rencontres de
quidditch le sport du sorcier et des
duels de sortilèges cd principe assez
simple embardée livre on regarde comment
les gens meurent et on essaye de
prévenir ça donc quelques mouvements des
skis et puis derrière on apprend les
mouvements basiques de baguettes une
journée dans un autre monde pour les
fans à conserver précieusement dans une
pensée et c'est la fin de ce premier set
it loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis
bonne soirée à jeudi prochain
[Musique]
on